work until we have to die just for the
privilege of being alive we have to work
somewhere just to afford a house that
we're never at because we're working to
afford the house is the meaning of life
to work and pay taxes and then die on
top of that we also have to work to
afford our vehicle to get to work in
other places and afford gas just to get
to work and we also have to pay taxes
for our roads to drive on to get to work
and then we have to work for our
children to go to school to learn how to
work if the only places you work are
soulless
giant corporations that you know the
only thing you're contributing to is a
few people at the top getting rich
you're not you haven't connected what
you do to you're not solving a problem
for somebody y um you are a cog in a
machine you are a car in a traffic jam
then that sort of desperation Rings true
and I get that yep